can a mustache kill a movie you betcha
just ask Henry Cavill and Joss Whedon
this is the story of Superman's brush
with infamy and the Fallout that
followed Khalil the last son of Krypton
famously gains his powers from exposure
to Earth's sun aside from a slew of
abilities that includes flight super
speed and x-ray vision one thing that
puts the man in tights in a league of
his own is his invulnerability after all
he's not called The Men of Steel for
nothing naturally then a standard razor
should stand no chance of clipping Clark
Kent's facial hair to the baby-faced
cleanliness that has become standard for
the fictional character the uncertainty
around kalel's shaving technique became
the theme of an ad campaign from
Gillette in 2013 corresponding with the
release of Henry cavill's Premier outing
as Superman Man of Steel the company
went all out in an attempt to answer
this comic book riddle the company
assembled a Justice League level group
of nerds to present differing theories
from director Kevin Smith to Bill Nye
and fans were asked to make a vote for
their favorite Theory online other
people have suggested the Kryptonite
razor as if that's simple would you
shave with death ladies and gentlemen of
course not however Gillette must have
missed the episode of Superman the
animated series in which Clark Kent gets
that perfect smooth trim using a mirror
and his powerful heat vision two
products that the company sadly doesn't
sell since the first comic book
appearance of Superman in 1938's Action
Comics number one the clean chin and
upper lip have been a staple for the
character's Visage although he has
disguised himself many times over the
years the clean-cut look is as much a
part of soup's costume as the S on his
chest Clark Kent does have the ability
to grow facial hair though Superman
number 139 features an entire storyline
around the effects of red Kryptonite
weakening kalel's powerful Vision
resulting in his hair and fingernails
growing far more than is appropriate for
Kent's Deja job at the Daily Planet so
it's not that Superman can't grow a
sweet stash but rather that audiences
change their opinion regarding the True
Blue Hero when he Sports facial hair
generally Superman Dawning appeared
insinuates that the bald-faced crime
fighter has been absent for a period or
aged considerably as seen in Superman 3
something as insignificant as a five
o'clock shadow can even make Superman
look like an evil version of himself
meanwhile the Clean Cut helps to fortify
Clark Kent as the responsible Boy Scout
he traditionally represents while Henry
Cavill has been limited to filming less
than a minute of screen time as Superman
in the last five years the actor's early
days in the blue tights were highly
productive making his debut in 2013's
Men of Steel solo flick kavel continued
his time in the spotlight with Batman v
Superman dawn of Justice in 2016
powering through that movie's poor
critical reception production for
cavill's next adventurous soups began
less than a month later unfortunately
unbeknownst to everyone involved during
those first days of filming Justice
League was about to unravel the entire
DC EU
booyah
at the conclusion of Batman v Superman
supes is defeated by the Monstrous
doomsday and the first half of Justice
League is built around the rest of the
team bringing him back to life as such
the man of Steel's screen time is
limited compared to his superpowered
colleagues notably though even after
being raised from the dead Superman
maintains his baby face trim presumably
every scene that cavil shot for Justice
League during principal photography
which wrapped in October 2016 featured a
clean-cut Clark Kent the process of
bringing Justice League to life was
tumultuous to say the least originally
Warner Brothers had struggled to get the
movie going after first announcing a
pre-dc EU version in 2007 as production
finally loomed in 2016 Zack Snyder's
original proposal of a two-part film was
nixed by the studio even during filming
the backlash to the critically penned
Batman v Superman resulted in
substantial rewrites and changes in
producers still the most significant hit
to the film occurred in post-production
when Zack Snyder left the project due to
the sudden death of his daughter after
attempting to return to work Snyder
opted to completely step away from
Justice League in his announcement he
said in my mind I thought it was a
cathartic thing to go back to work to
just bury myself and see if that was the
way through it the demands of this job
are pretty intense it is all-consuming
and in the last two months I've come to
the realization I've decided to take a
step back from the movie to be with my
family be with my kids who really need
me as principal photography on Justice
League seemed to come to an end the cast
dispersed into other projects Henry
Cavill moved into production on the
action thriller night Hunter which
failed to Garner much positive attention
however it is notable for one particular
reason Cavill had grown a scruffy beard
for the project so when the actor
shifted to his next film Mission
Impossible Fallout the choice was made
to give his character a mustache follow
director Christopher McQueary later told
the AV club Henry just finished Night
Hunter and had a big beard and the
mustache and long hair when he came to
work he had cut his hair but still had
that mustache and he asked what do you
think I thought about it for a second
and said you know what let's go for it
unfortunately this offhand decision
would later lead to significant problems
when Castle received a call to return
for reshoots on Justice League three
months into filming on Mission
Impossible Fallout in the wake of Zack
Snyder's departure from Justice League
Warner Brothers and DC enlisted Joss
Whedon to take over who had previously
helmed Marvel's The Avengers and
Avengers Age of Ultron
Avengers
with yet another creative mind now
embedded in the Justice League scuffles
the studio agreed to two months and 25
million dollars worth of reshoots a
significant cost compared to the
standard reshoot budget of 6 million to
10 million dollars and a couple of weeks
aside from scheduling conflicts with the
movie stars the studio had its own
demands for the reshoots that would add
to this growing monster of a film first
the theatrical version was limited to a
two hour run time a demand made by
Warner Brothers CEO Kevin tsujihara more
challenging the release date of the
movie was kept in its tight November
2017 spot despite these multiple
obstacles Warner Brothers Executives
refused to consider any delays out of a
fear of losing potential Financial
bonuses ahead of an upcoming merger with
a t the problem of Henry cavill's
mustache served to distract from all the
other dramas surrounding the Justice
League reshoots the price tag Warner
Brothers faced for Justice League was a
approaching 300 million dollars with the
added reshoot fund meanwhile Paramount's
Mission Impossible Fallout came in at an
equally impressive 250 million dollars
obviously neither Studio wanted to face
the risk of a continuity error deal with
the CGI removal of kavel's facial hair
or worst of all have the actor wear a
fake mustache as Christopher McQueary
told the AV club I've worked with fake
mustaches before you can get away with
it for a shot or two but it doesn't work
over the course of a movie surprisingly
though the director was open to
compromise The Fallout crew tallied the
number of shots in which Cavill featured
and worked out how much those shots
would cost to reshoot three million
dollars Macquarie then suggested that he
shut down production on the movie while
Cavill grew his mustache back while
Warner Brothers simply would pay
Paramount for the loss Paramount however
refused to let McQueary do this because
he was under contract caval was forced
to keep his thick mustache during the
Justice League reshoots in an unpleasant
twist of fate Fallout ended up having
shut down production anyways after lead
actor Tom Cruise broke his ankle on set
as the dust settled on the studio War
the task of disguising cavill's mustache
landed in the lapse of visual effects
artists and it didn't turn out well you
won't let me live
he won't let me die the first leaked
images of the cropped mustache quickly
took over the internet to heavy mockery
in the aftermath an anonymous visual
effects artist for DC opened up in a
Reddit AMA that has since been archived
notably the unnamed VFX crewmate passed
the blame for at least one particularly
terrible shot they said I'm not sure
which other Studio did that opening shot
on the cell phone but it's Dreadful it
shouldn't have been approved internally
let alone gone all the way to make it
into the film perhaps inevitably Henry
cavill's botched lip job became one of
the hottest topics on social media caval
himself however enjoyed the process of
becoming the internet's favorite joke he
told yahoo.com I sure wasn't expecting
that to happen I love that it has it's
cool I can show my grandkids one day it
didn't take long for Cavill to stoke the
Flames of the meme sensation either the
actor took to his own social media
sharing a picture of a strange-looking
Contraption from the set of Mission
Impossible fall followed the caption
read pictured above is in fact the
latest in a series of weapons being
designed by Warner Brothers and
Paramount Studios to combat The Entity
known as Henry cavill's mustache it is
not a question of if I should shave it
is a question of how can we possibly be
victorious against such a beast without
bringing our own Doom raining down upon
us sadly Cavill later paid farewell to
his furry friend in a heartfelt
Instagram post that featured a long
mustache Montage backed by Sarah
McLaughlin's I will remember you I tell
you this though
I will remember him always the drama
behind Justice League caught up with the
film upon its release the movie
officially premiered in November 2017
pulling in 96 million dollars from the
domestic box office on opening weekend
short of the 110 million dollars the
studio had projected the lowest opening
of any dceu project at that point part
of the failure was down to theatrical
competition from Thor Ragnarok and Coco
it certainly didn't help though that the
backstage confusion behind Justice
League translated so obviously onto the
big screen meanwhile fans were anything
but impressed that Superman was absent
from the majority of Justice League's
theatrical cut an issue made worse by
the movie's strange pacing worse still
cavill's uncanny CG face had apparently
gone unfixed for the Cinematic debut
leading to even more insults regarding
sloppy VFX fans weren't sure what to
expect from Justice League after the
disappointment of Batman v Superman and
the surprise success of wonder woman
sadly with this movie all of the DC eu's
Myriad of problems seem to come together
at once in an unprecedented maneuver
from Warner Brothers the studio gave
Zack Snyder another chance to finish his
vision of Justice League folding to a
massive social media campaign calling on
DC to release the Snyder cut Warner
media subsidiary HBO Max handed the
director 70 million dollars to rebuild
the film utilizing the photography that
he had already completed with a unique
post-production process taking place
during the covid-19 pandemic the
restructured four-hour Zack Snyder's
Justice League was released exclusively
on the streaming platform in 2021 Snyder
pulled no punches discussing the
theatrical release of the film which he
claims is never watched at a Comic-Con
event he said I would destroy the movie
I would set it on fire before I would
use a single frame that I did not
photograph
and as for the infamous Superman stash
it's sad to think that that would have
been the last view that people had of of
Superman was just that
[Music]